thank you all so very much I really love
performing that piece it's by Canadian
composer James Wright and it's based on
the letters Beethoven wrote to the
person he called his immortal beloved so
think for a moment about how the music
made you feel sad happy melancholy
joyous Robert Satori is going to talk
now about how music brings about these
emotions Robert is a senior fellow in
the as reality program in brain mind and
consciousness at CFR a cognitive
neuroscientist at McGill University and
founding co-director of the
international laboratory for brain music
and sound research his research focuses
on brain function and structure with a
special interest in music and speech
today he will talk to you about the
complex neurology behind our experience
of music and how it gives rise to
pleasure and emotion interestingly
enough he too is a trained musician who
studied as an organist so please join me
in warmly welcoming professor Satori
thank you very much Julie thank you all
for being here this wonderful evening
and with this wonderful trio before us
and I want to be sure to acknowledge the
fact that this whole show was set up by
the Canadian Institute for Advanced
Research with the support of the Israeli
Foundation and the the program in fact
is focused on the brain and
consciousness and it's a little broader
than that as well it really focuses on
some very complex and poorly understood
functions the most the highest sort of
cognitive functions that we humans are
capable of and sometimes people ask me
well why do you study something like
music what and what's the point of that
there are many answers to that but I
sometimes point them to this statement
which is literally carved in stone on
the front of our Institute on University
Street in Montreal or it's actually a
cool a on the dome because it's it's
actually a concrete I think not stone
and Wilder Penfield who was the founder
of our Institute basically said that
what neuroscience is all about is trying
to understand what it is to be human how
is it that the brain allows all of the
functions that we have that make us
human and I think in that context
understanding complex phenomena like
consciousness like music like aesthetics
I think is essential because I would
argue that without those things we
wouldn't be human so Julia earlier
alluded to the origin of music and she
mentioned that it was sort of a puzzle
for Darwin as to why we even have it and
indeed he at some point sort of throw up
his hands and said well it's one of the
most mysterious faculties with which we
are endowed and he didn't really have a
very good idea of what it was all about
but in the latter part of his life he
reflected on various aspects of his life
he had this to say in his autobiography
he said if I had to live my life again I
would have made a rule to listen to some
music at least once every week for
perhaps the parts of my brain now
atrophied would have kept been kept
active through use so this is sage
advice from a sage man and then he went
on to point out that without music there
is a loss of the moral character and
there's a weakness of emotions and so
indeed even though in his theoretical
understanding he didn't have a good
response about music in his own sort of
personal understanding he did he had a
very profound understanding that music
is really about communicating and
expressing emotion and feeling and that
it also keeps our brains healthy so
we're going to try to probe into this
brain that allows us to produce and
understand and perceive music and this
diagram is from a paper actually we
wrote with one of my former students
Joyce Chen is now scientist here at
Sunnybrook and Virginia opinion and what
we were trying to do is point out that
the brain not only has to precede music
it also has to produce music because if
no one produces music you can't receive
it right so it's kind of a loop because
the brain controls the motor actions of
the muscles that allow you to produce
music but at the same time those motor
actions produce sounds which influence
subsequent motor actions so it's very
much a loop in that respect and it's a
very complex system of course I'm only
giving you kind of a character of it
this evening but here's a sort of a
close-up and don't worry there won't be
an exam at the end where you have to
remember the denominator but I do want
to call your attention to this area in
the temporal lobe here the auditory
cortex because that's where impulses
come in through the ear and then go
through the brainstem and end up in the
cortex there and then there are a series
of cortical circuits which are quite
complex
that interconnect the auditory areas
with regions that have to do with motor
control in particular the promoter
regions and areas of the prefrontal
cortex and I'll come back to this idea
that these circuits are essential in
enabling many of the functions that are
the reason why we're able to both
produce and perceive music now we want
to probe inside the brains of musicians
how do we do that there are various ways
Laurel Illustrated some very elegant
studies using EEG which allows you to
look at temporarily unfolding events
with great precision we in our lab at
the Montreal Neurological Institute have
used various techniques but in
particular magnetic resonance imaging
because that allows us to pinpoint the
location of brain areas that are active
during particular tasks that are of
interest and one such function of
interest is the performance of music and
so in order to understand the
performance of music you actually have
to get people to play music inside an
MRI scanner and I don't know how many of
you have been inside an MRI scanner but
it's it's a rather confined however we
have been able to work with some music
technology engineers to build us some
instruments and if we can go to the
video this will illustrate the basic
idea behind what we're trying to do is
to use music in a global way to
understand brain function
I look at what happens in the brain when
cello players are playing the cello
which is exciting to me because I am a
cello player and a neuroscientist
playing the cello inside of the MRI is
definitely very different than playing
the cello outside of the MRI for
starters you have to be lying down which
is a non-standard position for a chalice
to be in there are also the constraints
inherent in the instrument itself being
that it doesn't actually have a resonant
body so you don't get the vibration
feedback that you're used to getting
from your instrument it's also equipped
with gut strings which are a very
different feeling than the metal strings
they're much harder to get sound out of
so in this experiment for the first time
we're looking at how the brain of a
highly trained musician specifically a
cellist is working when they're playing
their instrument so this is a very cool
device that was actually built for us by
Ephraim Hollinger who is another person
who's somehow ended up in Toronto I
don't know why they all come here
so Avram built this device which allows
us to actually look at brain activity of
a professional cellist when they are
doing their thing and what we see when
we look at this pattern here so this is
showing you the green areas or areas
that are more active during the
performance of the instrument than
during other conditions and we see
indeed some of the same circuitry that
was shown here and I hasten to add that
this paper was published in 2007 and
this result was obtained only a couple
of months ago so I you know we weren't
sort of faking it
and the areas involved are of course the
auditory cortex and over here in the
parietal lobe and this frontal cortical
area and part of what this shows us with
some analysis of the interrelationship
between those regions is that these
regions are working together as a sort
of unit because when you're playing the
instrument you not only have to produce
the sound but you have to adjust the
position and the pressure of your motor
action in order to get just the right
pitch so the auditory and motor systems
are in constant interaction under those
kinds of conditions now in order to be
able to play an instrument if you take
highly trained musicians like we have on
stage here you have to undergo many many
years of practice and training and
another feature that we've been trying
to understand is how the brain changes
as a consequence of all that training so
one nice thing about MRI is that we can
not only look at brain activity so as
we're looking at there with functional
magnetic resonance image but we can also
look at brain anatomy so here are some
images of the amount of cortical
thickness that is different between
people with musical training and people
without this is from some work done by
Patrick Bermudez who actually wasn't
trying to became back to Montreal
is in our good books and what Patrick
discovered is that there are areas of
greater cortical thickness so the actual
amount of gray matter in the brain is
greater in the auditory areas here in
the right and in the left hemisphere as
well as in the motor cortex and also in
the frontal cortex so we interpret this
as evidence that there's a certain
degree of plasticity meaning that the
brain of a musician has adapted to be
able to do what they do so well and
indeed the regions that are involved are
many of the same ones that I've just
shown you are involved in the playing of
the instrument now another very
important feature is not only the amount
of practice that you have but also the
age at which you begin to train and not
only in the case of music but in many
other domains as well
sports and vision and so forth it is
shown that the early training is more
important because the development of the
brain has more plasticity than later on
in life and actually I'm just wondering
for our musicians I'd like to know what
ages they started their their musical
training so how old are you when you
first started taking lessons three and
Jamie five and Rowan
six so you were you were just you were
just on the edge there
now I started training as an organist
when I was 13 and this is why these guys
were on stage playing and I'm giving a
lecture and we know that these factors
play an important role because if we
look at the again the anatomy of the
brain as a function of the age at which
training began and this is controlling
for the total number of years of
training so it's just about the age at
which training began we see that there
are changes in some of those frontal
areas that I showed you in the previous
slide this is work done by and Bailey is
another another one who moved to Toronto
working in Virginia Benjamin's lab and
not only is there a change in the
cortical structure but also that
cortical structure allows you to perform
more synchronously so when the musicians
are playing together they are better
able to tap in synchrony or move in
synchrony if they had that earlier
training so some of those phenomena that
Laurel was talking about the degree of
extreme position that's necessary when
they play which you can hear is really
much easier to achieve if you begin
training early it's not impossible to
achieve if you begin later but it is
more difficult okay so that is a lot
about the performance aspect and I want
to move to a different feature that
involves some of the same brain systems
and that is the ability to imagine music
musical imagery it's the ability that we
have to imagine the sounds of music and
I've put Beethoven here because in a
little while at the end of the evening
we're going to hear the trio perform the
the archduke trio and this is actually
some of Beethoven sketches for that
piece and that piece was composed around
1811 and we know that Beethoven was
already quite deaf by then because in
1802
he wrote his famous Highlander sh'not
Testament basically a long letter where
he pours out his heart about the fact
that he's going deaf and he is even
considering suicide because it's so
difficult for him to consider this and
yet he persevered and what's remarkable
of course is that even at a point in his
life when he was really quite completely
deaf and there's very good documentation
of this he was able to compose
magnificent music which means that he
must have been able to imagine it
extremely clearly and well to be able to
write it down so that's really quite
remarkable now how do we study that in
lab well we have different sorts of
approaches but one of the one of the
approaches that we've use we're going to
try to simulate here in the in the
concert hall so what's going to happen
now is the following the musicians are
going to play an extremely well-known
tune that you will recognize instantly
but they won't play the whole thing
they'll play about the first half or so
and then they'll stop your job is soon
as they stop you have to imagine the
rest of the tune as it would normally
play out in the appropriate rhythm and
so forth you really need to just imagine
that sound in your mind's ear and when
you get to the end of the song okay at
the very end when the when you're
imagining in your imagination has
stopped then you press your clicker you
got that okay so the musicians will play
you'll stop halfway through and then you
continue in your mind and then you click
when you get to the very end and then
we're going to see when the clicking is
happening please
okay some of you were were asleep
maybe that's it there's you were
supposed to actually stop you weren't
meant to keep singing because it is kind
of you can if there's anyone that can't
get out of it you know so the idea here
is that hopefully most of you experience
the ability to imagine the continuation
of that song and what happens in our
experiments is that we actually scan the
brain during that silent period when
people are imagining something like that
when there's no actual sound but they
they're trying to recreate the sound in
their mind and when we look at the brain
activity associated with that we see the
following so in the here's a lateral
view of the brain again in the orange is
the auditory cortex which is active when
people are listening to real sound
that's the control condition when they
hear the actual music and then during
the silent period some of those same
regions are active so in the green
regions we see parts of the brain that
are active both for the real music and
in silence when you're imagining the
music so portions of the auditory cortex
which respond to real sound also respond
to internal sound which is really pretty
amazing because there's no actual sound
there and yet those neurons are active
in addition some of the same regions we
saw before in particular here the dorsal
premotor cortex that's typically very
much recruited during these kinds of
tasks because imagination is an active
task it actually requires we think a
motoric component as well as a
perceptual component and so this
circuitry that we're talking about is
really interesting because it is able to
be put to work not only for decoding
external stimuli but also for internal
recreation of previously experienced
information there's another feature that
I want to point out of this auditory
frontal Network and this relates to some
of the things that Laurel mentioned
which is the ability to
anticipate events so Laurel mentioned it
primarily in the context of rhythmic
events anticipating when something will
happen but it's also possible to
anticipate the nature of the event so
for example in this study carried out by
Marcin reasoner what we see is that both
auditory and frontal cortex respond to a
deviation from what's expected and this
sort of experiment you hear a sequence
of tones and then at some point a tone
is presented that was not one of the one
of the ones in the sequence previously
presented and so therefore it's a
deviation from the regular expected
pattern and the nervous system in
general is very sensitive to deviations
from regularity the important point here
is that you can't respond to a deviation
if you don't have a model of what it is
that's going to come in other words you
have an expectation you have a
prediction of what's going to come and
then what that what does come differs
from what was expected and that's the
deviation if you have no capacity to
generate that prediction you won't
notice anything that's deviant right so
we're going to come back to that topic
in the context of emotion in a couple of
minutes so I've been telling you about
these circuits which start in the
auditory cortex and of course the
auditory cortex is responsible for our
ability to perceive sound and our
ability to perceive relationships of
sound rhythms and harmonies and tonal
patterns and musical intervals and so on
and so forth and I've also talked to you
about these pathways that go from the
auditory cortex into other parts of the
brain and actually feed back eventually
back to the auditory cortex and these
loops so-called are important not only
for sound but also are enhanced by
training and are necessary for the
production of music so there's a very
nice parallel between production and
perception as well I've Illustrated
evidence that some of these same
circuits are important to enable our
ability to imagine
sounds and that these systems are highly
sensitive to regularities and therefore
are able to generate expectancies but
what does all that have to do with
pleasure because I promised you in the
title at least that I was going to tell
you something about pleasure and we've
already heard about emotion and music
and pleasure I would argue is a very
significant aspect of the emotional
impact that one gets from music in fact
one of the ways that we look at this is
by measuring when people experience a
strong pleasurable response to music so
that they get chills or sort of shivers
down the spine how many of you have
experienced that this evening it's quite
a few of you I'm sure
maybe when Julie hit that high note that
was that was one one moment for me I
think it was during Auto neopor tenure
and that's possible because I'm from
Argentina so I have a strong connection
to that music so when we talk about
pleasure we're actually talking about a
very different system than this cortical
system we're actually talking about a
system deep in the brain so in this
illustration here there's a cutout and
you're seeing some of these deep
structures basal ganglia and it's
actually a very complex system again I
emphasize these are highly
oversimplified sort of diagrams there's
a lot of other structures in the medial
frontal lobe and also in brainstem
nuclei but one of the most important
components of this system is the so
called striatum which actually consists
of two sub parts which we'll get back to
in a moment and these structures are
interesting because first of all they're
phylogenetically very ancient in the
sense that if you look in the brain of a
salamander you will see that they also
have Australia and similar in in
structure to ours and furthermore these
systems tend to be important for what
biologists have called stimuli or events
that are essential for survival of some
sort so for example they would respond
to a food reward so if you take a lab
rat and you
feed at a certain amount of food areas
in the stratum will respond because it's
a pleasurable sensation similarly these
regions have been shown to respond to
sexual stimulation and both food and sex
are obviously essential for survival
food for the survival of the individual
sex is obviously necessary for the
survival of species because without
reproduction you wouldn't have the
species and it's also been shown that
the same system responds to certain
kinds of drugs like and para means
cocaine alcohol part of the reason
they're so powerful and dangerous is
because they have a direct chemical
action on this system so a few years ago
we were wondering about music and why it
gives pleasure and we know from a vast
amount of literature that this is the
system that is associated with strong
pleasure and so we wondered could it be
that music would engage the same system
because after all music is nothing like
any of these other stimuli it's not a
substance it doesn't have a direct
chemical effect and strictly speaking
it's not even really necessary for
survival you might be miserable without
it but you wouldn't be dead without it
right so we've done a series of
experiments that show that indeed it is
the case that this area of the stratum
is active is responding to very strong
musical pleasure and we've done it in a
number of ways using a number of
different techniques these are all
vertical cuts through the brain like
this and you see the activity in these
deep structures ventral striatum here
also here and also here with different
measures in the older studies we did it
with just looking at cerebral blood flow
and more recent studies were able to
look at dopamine which is important
because dopamine is a neurotransmitter
and it is the neurotransmitter that is
most important in signaling reward and
many of those animal studies that I
mentioned that's the sort of molecular
signal that
there's a strong salient and pleasurable
stimulus there and I'll come back to
this third study in in just a second but
in this one which is carried out by
valerie salim poor one of my former PhD
students we noticed something which is
that they were actually sort of two
blobs you can probably see there's one
more in the upper part of the brain
dorsal striatum and one in the more
ventral region and we wondered why there
were those two responses and so with a
little bit of careful analysis Valerie
was able to demonstrate that there's two
separate phases of the response so one
of them is in the dorsal striatum and
one of them is in the ventral stratum
and they're divided according to the
moment of the peak pleasure so in these
experiments we have people listen to
music that they themselves have selected
as chill inducing so this is not hard to
do people have lots of recordings that
they say every time I hear this passage
there's a particular spot and oh my god
is just wonderful and when that happens
they indicate to us that it's happened
by pressing a button we can also measure
physiological responses like heart rate
and so on and what happens in the brain
is really quite interesting because in
the moments prior to that peak pleasure
there is a response here in the light
blue line in the dorsal stratum which is
this area and then at the moment of peak
pleasure it goes down whereas the
ventral striatum which is down here is
slightly active during that time but
then immediately when the peak pleasure
moment arises that's when it really
strongly shoots up and so this means
that there are actually two different
things going on one is the actual
experience of that pleasure when you
really feel that chill but on another
and I think extremely important one is
this anticipatory phase and this is I
think again related to some of the ideas
that Laurel told us about now we're
going to try to do a little experiment
here and probably if there's an ethicist
in the audience I'll be in trouble
because I haven't gotten in
form consent from you however we're
going to try it anyway and the idea here
is that I'm trying to have you
understand this idea of anticipating and
then receiving the element or the
stimulus that you expect based on what
came before it
so our trio has kindly agreed to play
the same segment of music with three
different endings okay and what I want
you to do is very simple you're going to
hear each of these three and I want you
to at the end after you've heard all of
them so just hold off until you've heard
everything at the end once you do a vote
for the one that you found most
pleasurable so this same piece of music
three different endings and at the end I
want you to use your clicker and decide
if it's number one number two or number
three and now no laughing this is an
experiment
now number three please okay now you get
to vote which of those three did you
find most pleasurable okay so that's
very interesting experiments don't
always work I think I just lost a beer
over this so the first the first one was
actually the conventional ending which
is to say it's the most predictable and
standard one the second one was slightly
non-conventional but actually still
within kind of a tonal structure and the
third one was completely unpredictable
essentially random set of notes that had
no relationship to what came before so
at the very least most of you except for
a few recalcitrant people and and maybe
you need to come to the lab later to
we'll check out your your auditory
cortex
so what's interesting here is I think
that this whole idea of predictability
is obviously playing an extremely
important role because you obviously
preferred the one that would had the
highest predictability which means that
you were able based on the first set of
notes to anticipate that that ending
should have a certain sound right so if
you haven't been able to do that you
wouldn't have shown any particular
preference and I think in the context of
music both the performance of it and the
composition of it musicians know this
musicians understand the idea of playing
around with the tension and the
resolution that's afforded by our
ability to have these expectancies that
are either met that are fulfilled or
that are not fulfilled and there's some
famous music theorists in fact who have
developed models about this so if we
come back to the brain for a moment
there's another aspect of musical
pleasure that we haven't entirely talked
about so up until now we've talked about
this sort of strong experience of chills
and and pleasure but most of our
experience when listening to music
doesn't necessarily involve such strong
pleasure sometimes it does and then it's
it's particularly wonderful but often
times we listen to music and we just
value it we enjoy it we like it but it
doesn't necessarily produce such a
strong response and we wondered whether
the same neural system is involved in
that sort of experience as opposed to
the very strong sort of physiological
alteration that you get with chills and
so in this experiment again Valery Salim
pour was the student who did the project
and she came up with the idea that we
could essentially use iTunes as our
model so what do we mean well in iTunes
you get to listen to an excerpt of music
and then you decide whether you want to
download it or not and you have to spend
a certain amount of money to download it
right so what we did is we put people in
the scanner and we had them listen to
pieces of music in fact these are new
pieces of music that had never heard
before but they were in a genre that we
were pretty confident that they would
probably like at least some of them and
then they had to give her a dollar
rating as to how much money they'll be
willing to spend for that piece of music
and then what we did is we look in the
whole brain and we used the dollar
amount to investigate which regions are
changing their activity depending on how
much value is assigned the value being
the monetary amount and what we see is
that that same region that had shown you
before that we saw in in the other
experiments so it's the ventral stratum
similarly to here similarly to there so
in that case we see that this system is
not only responsible for pleasure itself
but also is responsible responsible for
the value that we assign to music and
then we took one additional step and for
this aspect of the project we got help
from Randy Mackintosh here from the
Rahman who has some very interesting
ways of analyzing the relationship
between activity in one part of the
brain and in another part of the brain
by looking at the coupling between them
so it's sort of similar to what Laurel
was talking about we're looking at how
the fluctuations in brain activity are
they synchronized or are they not
synchronized and if they're synchronized
it must be because those parts of the
brain are somehow interacting and so
when we looked to see what other parts
of the brain were active with the
striatum we saw the auditory cortex
which is shown here in a coronal section
so what this is telling us is that the
auditory parts of the brain are
interacting with the reward parts of the
brain more and more as the value
increases
so when you really like something and
you're enjoying it and you want to buy
it in this particular experiment then if
there's a lot of communication between
those two systems compared to when you
are not so enthralled by it and
therefore aren't willing to spend money
on it
and I think this finding is really quite
important it kind of ties together a lot
of the themes that I've talked about
tonight because I've shown you earlier
evidence that this cortical circuit
that's on the surface of the brain
that's the most highly evolved part of
the human brain and that's the area
those are the systems that are important
for perceiving music performing music
and also for making these predictions
right for the anticipation that allows
us to decide whether the end or the
continuation of something is what we
expect it or not and that system is
coupled with the most phylogenetically
ancient system which is the reward
system which is key to our emotions and
it the idea that that we're sort of
working on at the moment is that this
interaction is really the reason why
music has such power in other words it's
bringing together the most highly
evolved parts of our brains that do
pattern recognition analysis of sounds
that are coming in predicting what's
going to happen next with the most sort
of strongly emotional parts of the brain
that have to do with the experience of
pleasure and that is probably why music
and perhaps other aesthetic experiences
are so powerful and why they're so
universal in our species and so I want
to leave you with that idea and just be
sure I thank all of the many people who
have contributed to this work all of my
colleagues some of whom are here this
evening
all of the students none of whom are
here because they're busy working in the
lab and again a special thanks to c4 and
the Israeli foundation for putting on
this whole show and to the funding
agencies that have been
generous with their support thank you so
much